hace cinco años atrás inicié mi primer
taller mecánico asociada
hace 1 me atreví a emprender sola
como ven
soy una mujer donde una emprendedora
donde comúnmente no hay mujeres
por ende llegar hasta donde estoy fue
una serie de procesos y obstáculos donde
toqué puertas recorrido buscando
oportunidades y siempre me encontraba
con un gran obstáculo tú no puedes
para eso siempre tenía otra pregunta por
qué no
no había respuesta que me dejara
tranquila para gto
cómo fue que una joven madre adolescente
estudiante mecánica
llegó a dar una traslación
bueno les explicaré de la manera más
sencilla y simple para mi construyendo
un vehículo si les voy a contar cómo
construir mi propio vehículo y volé
aunque parezca algo imposible
todo parte por el chasis es la parte
donde sostienen las piezas y ensambles y
sistemas del vehículo esa soy yo
sosteniendo cada pieza y sistema de mi
propia vida
todo parte también con la carrocería la
carrocería de la parte visible que todos
ves de un vehículo que sea grande que
sea ostentoso cuando ustedes van a
comprar un vehículo que su pintura esté
linda que no está apoyado que no esté
chocado muchas veces ni siquiera viendo
suficiencia su seguridad
así que conmigo también veían mientras
ys
sin poder saber lo eficiente que yo
podía ser trabajando
empecé a ensamblar mi carrocería desde
muy pequeña
a los nueve años ocurre un episodio que
me marcó mi vida y desde ahí en adelante
nadie pudo parar desarme el televisor de
mi casa estuvo malo una semana una
eterna semana para mí para mí sin poder
ver mis dibujos animados
entonces me aburrí lo desarme
empecé limpiando partes uniendo piezas y
estábamos junto a mi hermana frente al
televisor a la hora de la verdad tenía
miedo de que explotara
pero encendió y no explotó
pude ver mis dibujos animados mi primer
triunfo
luego de eso seguir creciendo y mi
carrocería fue modificándose junto
conmigo también siendo adolescente entré
a trabajar como yo ante mecánico en el
taller de mi tío
él con mucha paciencia empezó a enseñar
fue ahí donde con sólo 14 años de sangre
por primera vez el motor de un camión y
al igual que el televisor no explotó
y cada vez que yo pasaba delante del
camión estando su dueño ahí me apuntaba
y gritaba y me decía a llevar a la niña
que reparo mi camión y la verdad es que
yo me sentía algo de vergüenza si bien
es cierto me sentía contenta por mi
logro
pues también como me sentí validada como
mecánico pero sin embargo sentía como
que era un gran punto en contra ser
mujer
muchas veces me masculinizar on por eso
dudaron inclusive de mi sexualidad por
estar trabajando en un taller mecánico
fue entonces que decidí entrar a
modelaje para poder reafirmar mi venida
allí aprendí a usar tacos actualmente
tengo una colección de tacos muy linda
en mi casa aprendí a maquillarme a
peinarme a combinar colores
quería demostrar que podía ser femenina
y a la vez gustarme la mecánica
pero aún así ya estaba con el gran
cartel en mi carrocería de la machada
soy yo pasando el tiempo y mi carrocería
ha subido sufrió su primer top on su
primer avión
fui madre a los 16 años nuevamente
juzgada
y me dijeron que no podía seguir
estudiando como que prácticamente al ser
madre perdía mis capacidades de
desarrollo
no fue un obstáculo para mí continué
tuve mi segundo hijo a los 19 años
tampoco un gran obstáculo para poder
seguir adelante
fue en ese proceso alrededor de mis 20
años 21 años que ocurrió el choque más
grande de mi vida con daños casi
irreparables en mi chasis y carrocería
perdí la visión de mis hijos
nunca voy a olvidar las palabras del
juez cuando esa ves me dijo me miro a
los ojos y me dijo crezca desarrollo se
cumpla sus metas sean feliz porque sus
hijos también lo van a hacer
luche cuatro años incansablemente para
poder recuperarlos entremedio de ese
proceso
tuve un toque por el cáncer no era una
muy buena conductora la verdad
y
que hay en prisión por pensión de
alimentos
15 días en la cárcel y mil eternas
noches para mí
fue una lección de vida que nunca voy a
olvidar
pasó el tiempo pude salir de todo esto
recupere a mis hijos
recupere mi vida desarrollé mi
carrocería arregle micha 6 y seguía
siendo la mujer fuerte que todos veían
el segundo ensamble fueron las ruedas
debía poder desplazarme hacia donde iba
al igual que la amortiguación debía
tener una buena muy buena suspensión
para todo el camino que me tocaba
recorrer con tantos baches en el camino
como impedimentos debía poder amortiguar
cada golpe
también parte sistema de partes de este
sistema y muy importante también era los
frenos ya había chocado anteriormente
así que ocupe bastante mi tolerancia y
mi paciencia para poder frenar las cosas
ir sin freno por la vida puede causar
graves accidentes
según el tercer ensamble la dirección y
las losas todos debemos saber
direccionar nuestras vidas yo creo que
más de algún conductor aquí ha tocado la
bocina cuando un conductor delante va
doble y nos señalizar
nosotros debemos hacer lo mismo con
nosotros debemos saber y que el resto
sepa a dónde nos dirigimos mis luces por
fin poder entrar a estudiar mecánica
automotriz esto me da la claridad para
poder ver mis metas al final de mi
recorrido
la cuarta pieza y muy importante dentro
de vehículo su corazón su motor todos
tenemos un motor de nuestra vida mi
motor mis hijos
puedo tener unas buenas luces unos
impecables neumáticos unos muy buenos
frenos una muy linda carrocería pero un
vehículo sin un motor no es nada
serviría solamente para estar ahí de
bonito ver sus llantas pero no serviría
de nada es aquí también donde tenemos
que tener los mayores cuidados en un
vehículo así como nuestra vida también
debemos tener unas mantén acciones
buenas una mano un motor con malas
intenciones puede perfectamente
inclusive
morir
la quinta pieza y muy fundamental dentro
de un vehículo la línea de escape
es por aquí donde todos los gases del
proceso de combustión que se genera de
un vehículo se expulsa así también debía
ser yo a través de esta línea de escape
votar todos los prejuicios todas las
críticas todos los tu no puedes
y llevarlos por la línea escape
en la línea de escape también
encontramos el catalizador quien es el
que se encarga de tomar los los gases
tóxicos a contra para transformarlos en
vapores menos contaminantes
es aquí donde también tuve que aprender
a ser tolerantes con el resto y con las
opiniones de los demás por cada tú no
puedes por cada crítica por cada duda
incluyendo de mi sexualidad
bueno pude parar y botar estos gases y
decir por qué no
y saben que me di cuenta
somos muchas dentro de esto buscando
oportunidades recorriendo muchas veces
tratadas con inclusive hasta como bichos
raros pero si somos muchas ya no somos
bichos raros somos personas necesitamos
oportunidades para esto
mi nombre es valeska morales soy
mecánico madre soldador calificado y
dueña del primer taller mecánico
femenino de chile
mi gran meta es llegar a ser una
profesora con vocación y pasión en el
área de mecánica automotriz muchas
gracias